leute ich würde jetzt mal sagen ich bin
mir relativ sicher dass es dann diese
hier gewesen ist hat 28 euro kostet
anscheinend warum da jetzt so ein logo
drauf ist weiß ich nicht leute also
bitte seid nicht verwirrt durch meinen
gelaber am anfang es geht genau um diese
box die ich euch gerade gezeigt habe
jetzt auch noch erhältlich die wird
ausgetauscht also so wie ich sie damals
gestellt hat gibt es die nicht mehr auch
der rote button darauf hat sich
verändert aber das steckte schon alles
im video jetzt viel spaß und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video schalte
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen also ich hab ja
ende letzten jahres ein video gemacht wo
ich angeteasert habe das ist in diesem
jahr sehr viele videos gibt wo es um
produkte geht weil ich halt da bock
drauf hab so kam es auch schon einige
jetzt in letzter zeit nicht mehr so ganz
weil ich halt was anderes gefunden hat
was mir gerade noch mehr spaß macht
trotzdem habe ich gestern durch zufall
beim aufräumen ein paket gefunden was
ich auch damals bestellt habe also das
müsste so zwei drei monate ja dass das
war zu zeiten der alex pesch woche falls
ihr euch an die noch erinnert habe ich
diese musik box auch bestellt und wollte
die halt mal testen weil ich das auch
sehr interessant fallen und das habe ich
dann jetzt einfach auf heute verschoben
ich meine warum nicht gab jetzt länger
kein wunsch video und man muss ja auch
irgendwie seiner lieblings plattform ein
bisschen treu bleiben deswegen gibt's
heute wo ich wie ich video leute wir
haben nur ein kleines problem und zwar
habe ich die sachen damals alle über
einen anderen account bestellt weil ich
mir einmal so auch umsonst sachen dort
aussuchen konnte halt weil ich so viel
über die plattform halt gezeigt haben
oder so viele sachen ausgepackt habe und
ich bin mir jetzt leider nicht mehr zu
100 prozent sicher welche artikel ich
genau gekauft hab ich meine aber es
müsse so ungefähr dieser hier gewesen
sein weil ich mich halt noch ganz klar
daran erinnere dass es sich um ein fake
bbl produkt gehandelt hat oder zumindest
ein produkt was genau so aussieht ich
meine aber so welche stand sogar drauf
weil ich halt zu dem zeitpunkt auch viel
gemacht habt originaler playstation
controller fake playstation controller
von lowepro und also müll
ich habe mir allerdings die verpackung
natürlich schon angeguckt und auf der
verpackung sie das produkt extrem so aus
wie diese box hier wobei sich ja nur um
dieses case handelt für die originale
box als ich hoffe wir bekommen gleich
raus was ich genau bestellt haben oder
können zumindest eine
aufstellen will ich euch eigentlich auch
gar nicht lange auf die folter spannen
und wir fangen sofort man mit dem
auspacken weil hier irgendwelche
bewertungen vor lesen lohnt sich ja
eigentlich nicht wenn ich nicht mehr
weiß welches produkt das genau war ja
die haben wir das produkt ich nehme eben
noch meine sony kam dazu damit man das
ein bisschen professioneller gestalten
können ja die haben wir das schöne stück
preislich kann ich jetzt natürlich auch
nicht mehr genau sagen aber ich würde
mal sagen also es war zu hundert prozent
nicht teurer als 30 euro was ich dafür
bezahlt hat ich habe allerdings jetzt
genau das produkt gefunden um das es
sich hier handelt und zwar ist das also
zumindest von der verpackung her die gvl
boombox und freund von mir hat die und
die kostet sogar auf der offiziellen
seite 428 euro normalerweise sogar 499
euro
deswegen bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
was wir hier für 25 bis 30 euro dann
drin haben was so genau hier kann man
sehen also hier fehlt 100 das gm logo
einmal hier und hier auf dem bass und
dann sieht das aus wie das original um
ehrlich zu sein bisher aus rechtlichen
gründen nicht erlaubt hatten wir beim
iphone aus schon und ist die verpackung
auch schon der romanows kabel und ein
ladekabel doch mehr nicht mehr braucht
man ja auch eigentlich nicht und das ist
die box warte mal
jetzt hätte ich zumindest gedacht dass
hier wie auf der verpackung wieso haben
wir denn hier sonst ein rotes feld sieht
für mich aus wie so ein aufkleber den
man halt vielleicht machen kann und dann
steht das gm logo aber dem es nicht so
auch die seiten sind anders aus wir
haben wir sogar schon einige
gebrauchsspuren alles klar und das kann
ich jetzt nicht ganz genau sagen aber
die originale box ist soweit ich weiss
auch deutlich größer als das gerät hier
also mal um ein verhältnis zu bekommen
aus meiner hand hätte es gedacht hier
haben wir die anschlüsse auch so das
bild mini sd
und dann wollen wir schauen ob wir das
an kriegen aber wahr ist hoch so das
einzige was wir jetzt machen können ich
habe hier wieder ein gutes mikrofon dran
ist die bock jetzt mal an zu machen ich
finds auch selber bisschen schade dass
ich jetzt natürlich kein original des
vergleichs stück habt damit man da halt
den unterschied raushört aber ich denke
mal man sollte ganz klar hören wie gut
oder schlecht die qualität davon ist
meine erwartungen sind sehr sehr gering
märkte seien auch nachdem ich jetzt
gerade schon den staatsrat gehört habe
[Musik]
also die ist jetzt auch von der
lautstärke
[Musik]
das finde ich jetzt eigentlich passt das
hätte ich niemals gedacht also ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob wir das auch so sein
können aber für mich ist der sound okay
also erst jetzt nicht zu 100 prozent
komplett klar zum beispiel in meinem
auto oder so also wie beim boxen die
halt wirklich ein bisschen teurer sind
aber ich bin auf jeden fall ein bisschen
geflasht ist so gut ist ich stell dir
mal kurz denn in die ecke ich meine ich
glaube dass so ein ganz typischer raum
also oder ein zimmer wo man dann so eine
box stehen hat
eur vj
okay ganz angenehm ist das nicht aber
wir haben auch auf höchster stufe
ich mache noch mal ein bisschen leiser
wenn wir mal kurz meine eigene rost
yourself challenge von 2016 bis 2002
immer noch scheiße sagt wir waren wir
zusammen in der jugend bekannt
im ganzen land geringer arbeit heute was
mir aufgefallen ist wenn die verbunden
ist wir haben immer so ein ganz ganz
leicht einen piepton aber dass jetzt
auch nicht weiter schlimm
also ich muss sagen ich kann euch
versichern dass nicht über 30 euro
kostet die originale box ist noch mal
ein bisschen größer die originale box
ist noch mal ein bisschen größer kostet
aber ja das 14fache von daher meine
erwartungen daran waren jetzt deutlich
geringer ganz überzeugt bin ich jetzt
natürlich nicht also ich empfehle euch
das jetzt nicht aber wer eine box sucht
die jetzt nicht über 50 euro kostet oder
so und einigermaßen von den flinken
sound haben soll macht das hier mit gar
nicht so falsch also so ist meine
persönliche einschätzung
trotzdem wollte jetzt noch mal kurz
suchen häufig die ich finde also ich
muss ja irgendwann mal bestellt haben
vielleicht wird ja auch schon wieder
rausgenommen leute ich würde jetzt mal
sagen ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es
dann diese hier gewesen ist hat 28 euro
kostet anscheinend warum da jetzt von
logo drauf ist weiß ich nicht aber ich
bin mir sicher dass ich auf jeden fall
so ein fake gerät haben wollte was
möglichst so aussieht wie das original
und ja also an die von euch die sich die
jetzt holen wollen
probiert es am besten mit dieser hier
die sollte genauso gut funktionieren
ansonsten war es das mit diesem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
für weitere videos lassen wir immer gern
nach oben da und wir sind uns dann am
mittwoch wieder da gibt es ja ein
anderes cooles video auf das ich mich
schon freue
bis heute abend noch zu drehen das was
vor mir haut rein